hey guys it's justine and today is gonna
be a little bit different of a review
oh my god i just keep getting freaking
phone calls like how am i ever gonna get
anything done
hello if you got the test
[Music]
it's a freaking problem like spam calls
are such a problem that
oh shoot okay let me just answer this
really quick this may be a delivery i'm
expecting hello hello this is sam from
insurance wrong i would like to know are
you happy with your coverage because if
you're not we're running a special today
if you call in the next 24 hours
where was i i don't even know like this
is no joke i think for the past couple
of years i honestly hardly ever even
answer my phone like why would i most of
the calls are spam all of the calls that
i'm doing now are usually conference
calls and they're planned so if somebody
is calling me it's either one an
emergency two potentially food is at the
door or three it's a delivery so it's
like do i answer it do i risk maybe
talking to a spam robot person it's
really hard to say but today's video i'm
really excited because i'm partnering
with verizon and they've been the leader
in the fight against robocalls and i'm
really excited to show you guys this
call filter app which is a free solution
that is available to all verizon
customers to help you battle these
annoying calls it's funny because my
sister actually told me about this and
she's like wait you haven't downloaded
this yet what is wrong with you so she's
been using it for quite a while and now
since i've been using it i have been so
much less likely to answer a spam call
like i did at the beginning of this
video because clearly that was scripted
and fake and not real acting
wow so in this video today we're going
to be going over how to tell if a call
of spam what verizon is doing to help
and some other tips and tricks that you
can use to protect yourself now a lot of
these things may be second nature to you
but maybe your parents or your
grandparents could use some of these
tips feel free to send this video to
somebody who you think it may help
another spam
my light is moving and i think i might
have shaved off a few leaves of my fake
plant i'm gonna put this away maybe this
will do the trick
[Music]
maybe i'll just stick to the call filter
app so how can we tell if a call is
actually spam the thing is it's not
always the stereotypical irs so the car
warranty scammers they're getting really
smart now they're actually tricking us
into thinking that it's the doctors or a
healthcare provider which is really
uncool here are my top seven things to
look out for number one if they're
calling from some generic sounding
organization like health central 2020
the government or not even bothering to
identify their organization then uh
guess what
scam number two if there's pressure to
act now like this is an immediate thing
we have to do it now give me all of your
money uh yeah it's probably safe to say
it's a scam number three those recorded
generic calls from marketing agencies or
random unknown numbers uh yeah you
guessed it
number four if the caller claims to know
you but doesn't actually know your name
oh hey wonder what that could be scam
number five if the caller claims to have
some sort of pre-existing relationship
with you yet they can't even cite an
account number or they can't even prove
who they say they are scam number six
this is really important because
remember a legit business calling you
should already know everything that they
need to know about you you should not
provide any information to the caller at
all scam number seven if the caller
wants money cash cards social security
numbers credit card bank account numbers
your freaking shoe size your mother's
maiden name i could go on yeah you
better believe it's a scam i would love
to hear from you guys though are there
any of these calls that have actually
almost tricked you into thinking that
they're real leave those in the comments
below i would love to hear them so now
let's check out the call filter app this
is the free version and it has all kinds
of features like spam detection spam
filter blocked call log and one of my
favorite features is the neighborhood
filter so this is fairly new and it's
super easy to use and this scam gets me
all the time because i always like to
answer phone calls when it's from my
area code and i only answer it because i
think that it might be a friend or a
family member or there might be an
emergency from my hometown and guess
what no they're just wondering if i want
to extend my car warranty and do you
know what i don't want to do
well actually i might in some scenarios
actually
want to extend my car warranty so that's
not really entirely valid i will go to
the dealership and it will say let me
speak to a representative who can
actually extend my car warranty you
can't upgrade to the filter plus for
2.99 a month that has more features like
caller name id spam lookup personal
block list and spam risk meter but the
free version still has so many great
features that it will definitely make a
difference in helping you stop these
calls this is really awesome because
verizon is actually working with other
wireless network providers to exchange
authenticated calls using stir shaken
which is an industry-wide technology
that helps verify that the calls are
coming from the number on the caller id
and not being spoofed you're even able
to report calls that have not been
marked to spam easily through the call
filter app or by going to voice
voicespam feedback.com since i found out
about this i feel like i'm on some
personal mission to report all of these
calls when they don't get flagged
they're also working to identify illegal
robocall campaigns and work with other
carriers to trace them back to the
source and notify law enforcement using
this handy auto block feature this will
save you guys so much time and hopefully
it'll keep you from ever even bothering
to answer these calls in the first place
so the real question is what can you do
to protect yourself so i'd say the first
thing is if you're a verizon customer
definitely download their call filter
app now once you have it you can report
a number as spam which helps them
improve the overall spam detection
service also please do not share your
personal information including personal
identification numbers account numbers
any financial info absolutely nothing do
not share scam be aware of spoof phone
numbers that try and make you think that
it's a legit or someone that you might
know again did i mention don't click on
any links i mean just do not click on
any links even if it says hey you have a
package waiting for you don't click on
it if it says that you're getting money
through a text you gotta click it don't
and last but not least you can register
your phone number at do not call dot gov
okay so i know that was a lot but i was
really excited to see all the things
that verizon was doing to help battle
these robocalls for their customers that
i honestly couldn't wait to make this
video and i know this is a problem that
so many of us are having and it's so
obnoxious and so annoying that i'm so
excited that i feel like i'm a small
part of that reporting spam calls as
they come in like verizon you might want
to like think about maybe like starting
like some sort of superhero squad and if
you are uh can i please volunteer as
tribute i'm here again if you think this
video might help someone who has
potentially fallen victim to scammers
who have called or texted please send
them this video and hopefully together
we can stop this once and for all i will
put a link in the description where you
guys can learn more about the call
filter app and how you can download it
check it out in the description and i
will see you guys in my next video in
the meantime i need to work on some some
saber skills i think i need more room
definitely
definitely need more room and more
practice
okay bye
[Music]
you